"Forgive me, ma'am, but very few unaccompanied ladies travel beyond Omaha."
"Then they are missing some rare beauty."
"You're not a soldier's wife?"
"No. I'm a painter."
"A painter?"
"Yes."
"Darlin', I don't mean to be presumptuous, but you do have that certain look."
"What look is that?"
"The look of someone filled with good intentions...
...Western Missouri can be lethal."
"She came all the way from New York to paint Indians."
"I'm going to paint the Great Sioux chief, Sitting Bull."
"Is that a fact?" (spits)
"I have traveled many miles from the east, across many rivers and hills for the honor of speaking with you."
"You got a train from New York, right?
"Yes."
"Thanks."
"You're not good at keeping still, are you?"
"Shoot me, then I will be still."
"What would be the point of shooting you?...
...Bullets don't seem to have any effect."
"This is what's in my vision... My soldiers falling from the sky... Custer with his army..."
...They tracked down every chief. Killed them all."
"Except for you."
"The only battle I ever fought against is insignificance."
"So live more."
"That's what I want to do."
(whisper) "You look so magnificent."
"[unclear]. Do not give him reason to hope. No one here has forgotten or forgiven, least of all the Seventh Calvary."
"This ain't over until Sittin' Bull is dead."
"They will think that you and me are planning some kind of uprising."
"The people need a sign for them to believe in their own strength. They've been angry for a long time."
"Our fear is that his return to Dakota is about revenge."
"You idiots in Washington want to start another war."
"If we fight, don't massacre us all."
"This is what the General wanted all along. And deep down, that's what the Bull wants, too."
"I know terrible things have happened here in the past...
...I'm just here to paint the painting."